this case has the potential to end the
internet as we know it the internet
flourishes on user generated content
it's the backbone of the internet and if
you write or say something that is
illegal you can be held liable for what
you said but usually the websites that
host your content are not liable and
when you hear about section 230 this is
usually what we're talking about but if
websites were also liable for what users
say then websites would either shut down
almost everything or police things so
tightly that there would be basically
nothing even remotely objectionable
because if there's one thing that
websites hate it's being on the hook for
billions and billions of dollars of
potential liability and attorneys fees
and this isn't just some potential
hypothetical in the past when laws made
websites liable for user content they
just shut down the content and never
came back and one case before The
Supreme Court this term seeks to do
exactly that but for all of the internet
no joke this has the potential to end
the internet as we know it today so how
did we we get here how did I get here
well it started with a tragedy Naomi
Gonzalez was a design major at
California State University Long Beach
who was spending a semester studying in
Paris on the evening of November 15 2015
she was dining with friends at a cafe on
the Champions League when an Isis
terrorist with a gun open fired Gonzalez
was killed along with 130 other people
in coordinated attacks at six locations
across the city Isis claimed
responsibility for the attacks and
eventually 20 men were convicted of
crimes related to the massacre the lone
surviving gunman was sentenced to life
without parole so was Justice served
well the Gonzalez family contends that
it was not because there was another
perpetrator still at Large YouTube the
family sued Google which owns YouTube
alleging that YouTube's algorithms
amplify violent videos and hateful
content despite the company's efforts to
ban violent accounts and limit their
reach the Gonzalez family says that
YouTube's recommendations expose people
to hateful content radicalized viewers
and encourage them to make terrorist
attacks of their own Google argued that
because Isis not YouTube made and
uploaded those videos YouTube was not
the provider or developer of those
videos and therefore it was immune from
liability under 47 USC section 230
otherwise known as section 230 of the
communications decency act section 230
of the CDA immunizes internet services
for the content that its users upload
and often allows websites to remove
content without taking on liability but
the Gonzalez plaintiffs contend that
YouTube's recommendations should not be
covered by section 230 because the
company is acting like a content creator
rather than a publisher the ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals held that the
Gonzalez claims fell within section 230
and Google was immune from suit the
Gonzalez parties appealed and the
Supreme Court granted cert to answer the
question of whether section 230
immunizes an interactive computer
service from liability for recommending
other party content now in support of
their claims plaintiffs allege the quote
two of The Twelve Isis terrorists who
carried out the attacks used online
social media platforms to post links to
Isis recruitment YouTube videos and
quote Jihadi YouTube videos one of the
men who fired Gonzalez had appeared in
an Isis recruiting video in 2014. now
the plaintiffs argue that the defendants
violated the anti-terrorism act the ATA
by allowing Isis to post videos on
YouTube under Section 233 of the ATA as
amended by the Justice against sponsors
of terrorism act Americans who are
injured by quote an act of international
terrorism that has committed planned or
authorized by a terrorist organization
May Sue any person who quote AIDS in a
bets by knowingly providing substantial
Assistance or who conspires with a
person who committed such an act of
international terrorism and recovered
trouble damages so the legal question in
the lower courts was whether a social
media platform that was not used to
commit a specific quote active
International terrorism may still be
liable for aiding and abetting under
Section 233 the plaintiffs say that the
answer is yes that Google aided and
abetted an active International
terrorism conspired with the perpetrator
of an act of international terrorism and
provided material support to Isis by
allowing Isis to use YouTube and of
course the defendants say no the the
plaintiff's claims are barred by section
230 of the communications decency act
which often immunizes interactive
Computer Services AKA websites even when
they make targeted recommendations the
trial court and the ninth Circuit Court
of Appeals sided with Google ruling that
the claims fell within section 230
section c because Isis not YouTube
created or developed the relevant
content the court said that YouTube
quote selects the particular content
provided to a user based on that user's
inputs the display of recommended
content results from algorithms that are
merely quote tools meant to facilitate
the communication and content of others
and not content in and of themselves as
the lower courts noted the
recommendations are based on the user's
preferences not YouTubes the plaintiffs
argue that section 230c does not apply
to quote activities that promote or
recommend content so let's dig deeper
into what all of this means first of all
the plaintiffs are not simply arguing
that platforms are liable because
terrorists have used their services they
argue that the powerful algorithms that
recommend content are not covered by buy
the CDA because the recommendations are
content in and of themselves and as the
ninth circuit said the complaint alleges
Google uses computer algorithms to match
and suggest content to users based upon
their viewing history the Gonzalez
plaintiffs allege that in this way
Google has recommended Isis videos to
users and enabled users to locate other
videos and accounts related to Isis and
that by doing so Google assist Isis in
spreading its message so the plaintiff's
claim that YouTube facilitates
Communications between Isis and people
who watch their videos thereby aiding
Isis in recruiting new members the
plaintiffs acknowledge that YouTube
removed Isis videos and suspended or
blocked Isis users at various times
however the plaintiffs claim that
YouTube should have been able to stop
Isis from re-establishing the counts
using new identities and the plaintiffs
allege that Google left some of the Isis
videos up because they did not contain
content violating the site's policies
and other times Google remove the
offending content but did not suspend or
ban the accounts now we've talked about
section 230 of the CDA many times on
this channel section 230 was created
back in 1996 at the dawn of the internet
it has two key Provisions section 230c1
says quote no provider or user of an
interactive Computer Service shall be
treated as the publisher or speaker of
any information provided by another
information content provider this
sentence is often called the 26 words
that created the internet this section
stipulates that providing access to
third-party content does not make an
online provider the publisher or speaker
of that content now the second major
part of the law is section 230c2 the
so-called Good Samaritan provision which
states quote no provider or user of an
interactive Computer Service shall be
held liable on account of any action
voluntarily taken in good faith to
restrict access to or availability of
material that the provider or user
considers to be obscene lewd lascivious
filthy excessively violent harassing or
otherwise objectionable whether or not
such material is constitutionally
protected so this provision gives online
platforms broad immunity from liability
if they moderate content in good faith
this provision was meant to allow
websites to police itself without
incurring new liability because it was
an issue of knowledge a website might
not know what speech was hosted on that
particular website in which case they
wouldn't be liable for it but if they
knew that illegal speech or defamatory
speech or some other kind of speech was
hosted there and then took steps to
remove it from the website itself then
they actively had knowledge of that
particular speech and thus might become
liable for hosting it in the future so
websites found themselves on the horns
of a dilemma until section 230 of the
CDA was passed to allow them to engage
in good faith moderation because there
was generally a knowledge requirement to
be liable for things that were hosted on
your website if you had no knowledge of
what kind of speech was on your website
or platform then you generally weren't
liable for it but the argument went that
if you started to moderate your website
then that was evidence that you knew
what was on there and therefore you
became liable for all the stuff that you
were trying to remove from your website
this applied to spam them to pornography
to pirated media to defamation you name
it so the CDA was enacted in 1996 when
the internet was still in its infancy at
the time companies like America Online
confuserven Prodigy were the portals
that allowed people to access the
internet people could share files
exchange messages and chat with each
other in real time but that posed a
dilemma who would be liable if a user
posted something defamatory or shared
something else that was illegal would
liability go beyond the person that was
responsible for the post or would the
internet companies who hosted the
content also be on the hook and that
brings us to the distinction between
content Publishers Distributors and
platforms which is often completely
misunderstood in the pre-internet age
Publishers Distributors and platforms
were treated differently under the law
Publishers were newspapers magazines and
broadcast stations they were generally
liable for republishing material from
third parties since they solicited the
things that they published and they
could vet those materials Distributors
were businesses like bookstores
newsstands and libraries which
distributed material that was printed by
others and Distributors were not
required to assess every book that they
sold for example in 1950s the Supreme
Court overturned a Los Angeles ordinance
that said if you have obscene material
in your bookstore you can be held
criminally responsible and in that case
a bookstore owner was convicted of
violating the ordinance by selling a
novel called Sweeter Than Life which
tells the story of a quote ruthless
lesbian businesswoman the Supreme Court
said that the bookstore couldn't be
responsible for reviewing every single
thing in the book or magazine that it
sells and Distributors only had
liability if someone notified them that
Something They Carried was illegal
that's sort of the origin of the
knowledge requirement and platforms were
common carriers like phone companies and
television broadcasters platforms
weren't liable for third-party content
They Carried so for example let's say a
t found out that someone's answering
machine had a libelous outgoing message
was at T required to act by canceling
the owner's telephone service well the
court said no ATT couldn't be sued for
libel simply because the owner used its
service to say something libelous and
similarly a broadcaster wasn't liable
for running a political candidate that
falsely accused someone of being a
communist but then the internet came
around and the internet era posed A new
challenge for this case law two of the
first internet service providers can't
be serving Prodigy were sued for hosting
forums where users posted defamatory
content now Prodigy build itself as a
family-friendly version of the internet
did you get a computer recently well
congratulations you can now join
hundreds of thousands of discovered
Prodigy it moderated comments removing
things it thought were bad now
CompuServe didn't moderate anything
CompuServe combines the power of your
computer with the convenience of your
telephone and both of those companies
were sued for defamatory statements that
their users posted to the service now
the case against CompuServe was
dismissed because the court considered
it a distributor of content rather than
a publisher CompuServe could only be
held liable for defamation if it knew or
had reason to know of the defamatory
nature of the content and since they
didn't do anything to moderate their
forums the company couldn't possibly
know or at least argued it couldn't
possibly know about what the denizens of
rumorville were posting about each other
but Prodigy was found liable for failing
to moderate enough someone went on a
forum and claimed that Jordan Belfort's
investment firm Stratton Oakmont
committed fraud in connection with the
stock IPO The Firm sued Prodigy and the
anonymous poster for defamation and a
Court held that Prodigy was liable as
the publisher of the content created by
its users since it exercised editorial
control over the messages on its
bulletin board now if the name's Jordan
Belfort and Stratton Oakmont ring a bell
that's because they were literally
scamming people out of millions of
dollars and have gone down as some of
the biggest fraudsters in all of Wall
Street history the movie The Wolf of
Wall Street is based on the fraud that
they were perpetrating with respect to
the IPOs and it's one of the biggest
ironies in all of First Amendment law
that they won this lawsuit against the
people that were hosting presumably
accurate information about how they were
scamming people out of money that's part
of the problem when websites are liable
for user content is that people can file
lawsuits to stifle speech that's what a
slap lawsuit is all about and because
lawsuits are incredibly expensive
sometimes even if you scammed people out
of money as long as you file a lawsuit
you can stifle that kind of speech but I
digress as a result of these cases
internet service providers basically
either decided to not moderate at all
and leave absolutely everything up or
basically moderate everything and not
allow anything to go up and basically no
one was happy with this state of affairs
so Congress enacted the communications
decency act and then as now lawmakers
claim to be especially worried about
things like harassment and obscene
material so they gave online providers
immunity from lawsuits if they moderated
content and again the irony here is that
this legislation came from the sort of
family values type politicians the
people who always want to think about
the children
oh some
when someone got the children they
wanted to allow websites to remove
violent and sexual conduct so that the
internet could be even cleaner the same
politicians who wanted and got the
little parental advisory explicit
content warnings put on rap albums but I
digress again section 230 was intended
as a way for internet companies to
create and enforce basic standards to
run their websites and when the
CompuServe in Prodigy cases were decided
the courts only considered whether the
isps were Publishers or Distributors but
in Internet service like a website
didn't fit neatly into those categories
a traditional publisher has total
control over whether to publish content
a distributor can control what it buys
but it wouldn't have been practical for
a human to fully screen every item
modern social media companies host more
material than any library or bookstore
on Earth which makes screening all of
that info daunting if not impossible and
without section 230 social media
companies would be subject to strict
liability for every message in post made
on their services so Congress chose to
give those platforms and websites
immunity as an incentive to get them to
remove offending speech Congress also
chose not to dictate to those companies
which speech they had to remove so that
brings us back to the original question
in this case how should courts read
section 230 the lower courts follow the
tests set forth in the ninth circuit
case called Barnes versus Yahoo and the
Barnes test Hues close to the text of
section 230. the law specifies that only
one no interactive Computer Service
shall be too treated as a publisher or
speaker of three content provided by
another information content provider AKA
users and the plaintiffs argue their
claims do not treat Google as a
publisher but instead assert a simple
Duty not to support terrorists they said
that the ATA prohibits Walmart from
supplying fertilizer knives or other
material to Isis and in the same way the
ATA bars Google from giving Isis a
platform to communicate the ninth
circuit found this analogy specious the
idea of a Duty not to support terrorists
quote overlooks that publication itself
is the form of support Google allegedly
provided to Isis and publication of
third-party content is what section 230
gives to internet services according to
lower courts publishing encompasses
quote any activity that can be boiled
down to deciding whether to exclude
material that third parties seek to Post
online Google says that the CDA uses the
words publisher or speaker in an
ordinary sense but based on an ordinary
meaning a publisher or speaker is one
that publishes or speaks Google contends
that when YouTube's algorithms make
recommendations this activity is
protected by section 230 quote Congress
underscored that publishing for purposes
of section 230 includes sorting content
via algorithms by defining interactive
Computer Service to include tools that
pick choose filter search subset
organize or reorganize content Congress
intended to provide protection for these
functions not for simply hosting
third-party content and the plaintiffs
disagree their interpretation of the
section 230c defense is that it requires
a narrower interpretation of the word
publisher the ninth circuit previously
held at section 230c1 uses publisher in
its everyday cents and the second
circuit agreed but the plaintiffs
contend that the word publisher is used
in section 230c1 with a narrower and
distinct meaning which that term has in
defamation law basically the plaintiffs
are claiming that any time YouTube
recommends another video it therefore
becomes the speaker of that video as if
YouTube had produced that video itself
now defendants say that this
interpretation doesn't make sense quote
watch the World Series of Poker on
YouTube and YouTube's algorithms might
display Texas Hold'em tutorials that
does not mean that YouTube endorses
gambling any more than spell check
endorses a suggested substitute word
Westlaw endorses higher listed cases or
a chat room endorses post-organized by
topic as a ninth circuit noted YouTube
applies the same algorithms to all
content and it's here that I think
people often misunderstand the nature of
the internet and the nature of social
media with the case of YouTube people
upload millions of videos a day if there
wasn't an algorithm to sort through this
Deluge of videos the only way to sort
through them would be a fire hose of
viewing every video chronologically
which nobody wants it would be that or
doing a pointed search to try and find
content but then you'd never be exposed
to content that you actually do want to
watch but didn't know that you wanted to
seek it out and the plaintiffs have
tried to differentiate between search
results and other algorithmically
generated results but there's really no
principled way to distinguish between
results that are sorted when you
actively search for something versus
results that are presented to you
because of a recommendation algorithm
and people love to hate algorithms
myself included but the truth is if
there weren't algorithms to help us sort
through all of the content on social
media platforms it would be impossible
to Wade through it and then additionally
there's the issue of the material
support related for a claim under the
anti-terrorism act now the Department of
Justice is brief in support of the
plaintiffs argues that algorithmic
recommendations convey the website's own
implicit message that users will find
the information relevant and that makes
the website liable because it's acting
just like Isis itself now plaintiffs
didn't claim this in their original
complaint instead they focused on how
YouTube's recommendations amplify the
Isis speech making it more visible to
more users but the US government urged
the Supreme Court to adopt a narrow
reading of section 230 that would permit
a finding that Google materially
contributed to the content by matching
it to user preferences again basically
the Department of Justice as well as the
plaintiffs are arguing for a standard
that if any website promotes content
uses an algorithm or recommends content
to users that that website then becomes
liable for all of the speech contained
within that recommendation what happens
when websites are liable well remember I
mentioned that this has actually
happened before well it has in 2018 then
president Trump signed into law two
bills making it easier to fight sex
trafficking online that was the fight
online sex trafficking Act and the stop
enabling sex traffickers act otherwise
known as fausta and sesta and those two
laws created an exception to section 230
Safe Harbor rule by stating that
websites could be held legally
responsible if third parties posted ads
for prostitution on their platforms the
law penalizes websites which quote
promote or facilitate prostitution and
while this includes sites that promote
illegal sex work it also allows the
police to investigate any site that is
knowingly assisting facilitating or
supporting sex trafficking this language
can be read to include sites with
content that is legal such as escort
services personal ads and pornography
now critics of Foster and sesta warned
that the new laws were too broad and
they would end up killing internet
content that has nothing to do with sex
trafficking and they turned out to be
correct if a third-party posts content
that is covered by fosta or sesta and
the website fails to prevent that
content from being posted that website
can be sued and that was simply too much
legal risk for several websites
gone for the head
Craigslist shut down its entire personal
section Tumblr banned all adult content
and Reddit removed several subreddits
and other websites just simply shut down
entirely so you might ask did any of
this assist with the prosecution of sex
trafficking well in 2021 the U.S
government accountability office
released a report on the first three
years of fausta and sesta finding that
quote over three years the Department of
Justice filed just one case under its
rules against promoting or recklessly
disregarding sex trafficking so
ironically this provided essentially the
perfect natural experiment to find out
what happens when websites are liable
for the speech content of its users one
of two things will happen either the
website shuts down that section or shuts
down the entire department or the
website employs an army of moderators to
remove anything even remotely offensive
you basically either live in a world
where a website allows everything scams
spam pornography Ultra violence just
everything that you can possibly imagine
you probably don't want to see in your
everyday life or you live in a world
where they employed the extremely
expensive moderators who prevent
anything that might possibly be
offensive and that of course assumes
that a website can even afford to employ
those moderators so there are those who
want to see section 230 modified or
scrapped altogether and have argued that
these online services are acting like
content developers now oral argument in
front of the Supreme Court is next week
and I'm putting my money where my mouth
is on this one I filed a brief in the
Supreme Court along with Dr Mike
mythical entertainment chubby emu Tim
schmoyer and the author's Alliance and a
bunch of other creators we filed an
amicus brief explaining the potential
dire consequences of a really bad ruling
on this so we'll see how it goes but in
the meantime I'll probably just be
stress eating at the end of the internet
unless I use today's sponsor Factor 75
because Factor makes meeting your
nutrition goals easier than ever by
delivering fresh never frozen
dietitian-approved meals right to your
doorstep and the meals are completely
ready to eat other team of gourmet chefs
creates each meal using ingredients with
Integrity to help you feel your your
best all day long and I can tell you
from experience they really are
extremely delicious Factor supports
wholesome eating Made Simple their menus
are updated weekly with 34 different
options choose your favorite meals or
let Factor craft the order based on your
taste preferences and meal history
Factor takes the guesswork out of
grocery shopping and meal prep saving
you time and energy for other things
they're no hassle prepared foods make
sure you always have something
nutritious on hand when you don't have
time to think about making a meal and
sometimes I just want a good healthy
meal without having to cook or obviously
shop for the ingredients and factors
meals arrive pre-prepared and ready to
eat in just two minutes and I can always
scale up my meals if I need the extra
energy after a long day of lawyering so
give factor a try by heading to
factor75.com and use the code legal
eagle 50 to get 50 off your first Factor
box or just click on the link that's on
screen right now or down in the
description and use the code legal eagle
50 to get 50 off your first Factor box
and click on that link really helps out
this Channel and after that click on
this box over here for more legal eagle
or I'll see you in court